[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us at the round table
of dim lighting tonight we have Jason
mark dude has got a great story and a
great business he is the originator of
the sneaker drop off cleaning service
yes where you drop off your sneakers and
their cleans sneaker to hair sneaker
care is it's not just issues yeah this
guy cares about sneakers and he cares
for sneakers and we wanted to talk to
you know world where a lot of people
care a whole lot about sneakers we want
to talk containing not because now first
of all we're a whole lot more sneaker
head than we were say five years ago
I've informed a little bit but
definitely not actually sneaker heads
but right we are fascinated by people
who have made a decision to do something
where they followed a dream had an
innovative idea yeah it came to fruition
and the story of that like that
that's a mythical thing just like we've
been talking about we want to talk to
mythical people about mythical things
that they're doing the kind of embody
mythicality and Jason mark and body's
mythicality because he's doing something
that is completely original and creative
something that is kind of challenges a
paradigm and he's just he's just a good
guy local guy here so I would say Los
Angeles even if you're not in the
sneakers I think you're really going to
be into this conversation because it's
it's got this inspirational quality to
it that you can benefit from mythical
beasts nobody cried though I mean
spoiler I mean you got close there was a
there was a discussion about crying yeah
and there was a story that brought some
people to tears some people in some you
know is saying and he also there's some
blood involved at another point
serendipitously Wow he wore his mustache
tonight as did you yes which did you so
did you shave this in because you knew
Jason was coming and had a mustache no I
thank you for acknowledging my mustache
is there another reason for it
the reason is you know the reason yeah
I'm doing what they call playing dumb
link what I did the first thing I
noticed was not his his shoes it was the
fellow he's got a mustache too we're
mustache brethren did you now one of the
things we talked about is how you
acknowledge when somebody has the same
car the same shoes or whatever but did
you do a mustache acknowledgement
oh my god I know I did not nod at the
mustache but I assessed it so you looked
at his lip a lot of times I looked at
the mustache above the lip I know the
whole conversation you you can't tell
when somebody's looking at your mustache
or your lip okay what I can tell okay
what am I looking at right now the
microphone and when we're looking at my
mustache it's seriously looking at your
lips I mean I'm not comfortable doing it
now look at my mom cuz that's the kind
of look at my mustache now look at the
lips okay I could see that you see the
difference you can see the comparative
difference yeah but that's something
like is remembering like middle school
like Kate told me that if you want we
could have been Michael Juby I don't
know one of those guys that had kissed
some ladies and he was like you let a
girl know you want to kiss her when you
look at her lips so like you're looking
at her and then you look down to the
lips and you look back and you look down
at the lips and then she's like oh I
know what's up or you could just start
kit you could go in for the kiss well
you know or you I mean I'm not talking
about just like and you don't want to
just go in for the kids you want to ask
permission I'm not talking lease with a
look well I live I'm not talking about
like you just sit next to anybody I'm
talking about like you I loved there's a
relationship already happening so I'm
just like you and that's not what's
happening right now I'm just waiting
your must I wasn't I actually wasn't the
thought didn't cross my mind right yeah
so you clarifying it just made it weird
made it awkward of course my mustache is
not making anything awkward is it this
is this is day two of me having the
mustache cutting the mustache of cutting
it in you know I knew I wanted to grow a
mustache as an option for buddy system
season two mm-hmm
and I mean it's probably gonna be
they're all gonna be there but we still
reserve the right to not have it you
reserved the really say we I I mean you
had you do have a say yeah but I am weak
I think you get 51 51 percent right
which is basically the whole decision
there's only two no I I'm interested in
what you have to say but I miss the days
when my facial hair would change
constantly and you know I just like I
like have any option to do that for
buddy system because it could enhance
the story it should it can fit into what
we're doing something you drop something
you all right oh gosh what dude it's
behind you man
he's gonna keep winning one of those two
I was like hold down there it does what
is it that you're not talking about what
was I saying teaser you talked about how
you know the reason this isn't I had an
opportunity to have a mustache for buddy
system TV and it may enhance it may
enhance your performance and we're just
a few days away from starting to shoot
I'm very excited I'm kind of nervous but
the mustache I mean I had the beard you
know I don't I didn't want to just grow
in a mustache so I you don't do that no
one in their right mind just grows a
mustache you grow a beard and then
whenever it
you have a mustache within that beard
then you take the beard away yeah I mean
I think it is possible to do it the
other way but I do think that's you
doing it the easy way
well then you gotta explain like why
you're slowly growing a mustache there's
a lot of more every awkward phase yes
there's more yeah and all the
conversations like when you're growing a
beard oh you're growing a beard when
you're gonna mustache like keep going on
you need to bathe up there so now you
have to deal with and then I'm yeah I
have to deal with the shock of the
moment that I go I leave the Brett the
bathroom and I there's my family and
they all turn and look at me and haw
because I have a mustache they all hate
it do they know this was happening I
told him it was happening but until you
see it it's not something I it turns out
you're not prepared for according to
their response you know and then I come
into work yesterday morning so your wife
hates it
oh she hates it her dad had a mustache
for a long time really and he still
occasionally still has one and I don't
think she wants to be married to her dad
hmm that's weird that's just something
about their relationship I'm not gonna
play psycho I just mean specifically she
doesn't want to marry your dad well
that's a pretty simple thing it's simple
as a non psychologist I can confirm yeah
you don't have to be a psychologist no
that's a good idea
don't marry your dad dude but I think
the interesting thing is that there are
inch there are cultural connotations
associated with certain facial hair
configurations right that is a fact
and it's based on is based on these
principles that only exist in the
context of culture in other words if an
alien were to come down and his or her
ship and meet you and you were the only
human they would just make an
observation has hair over lower whole
you know I'm saying that's what they're
that ain't the lower hole row or hole of
the face that's a higher hole I got
nothing
face orifice well they wouldn't be
speaking English but you get I don't
know why they talk like a robot I don't
know either because they are as hair
over lower or a facial for ages or in
other words there would be no like must
be firemen they don't know that you know
they don't they don't know that you must
be volunteer firemen must get you know I
know there's other things that there's
other thing must be stuck in a tease
well there's lots of things with people
there's certain you know things that
people think that you might be into if
you have a mustache stuff that we won't
even go into my mustache isn't that thin
it doesn't even matter though I'm saying
that it's taller than that you have to
now deal with the perception that
people have of people with must but my
main my main concern is that it's like
you look old you look so much older you
look like a dad well first of all I am a
day who gave you that advice my my
family Christie say you look old I'm
like well you know I am Oh Rhett has a
beard lots of people have beards now and
they no longer have a connotation of old
or mountain men but that was probably
how it was before the reason we talk
about when I cut my beard off for last
season you did lucky like y'all I looked
like 24 right well I get baby but but
you would that beard doesn't look as old
as me with this mustache but the reason
why is not cuz it aided you is because
culturally it says so people associate
it with their dads or some I mean I
think we're getting out of that now like
I don't think Millennials dads have
mustaches or less of them did than like
our dads well had mustache well now the
thing is my dad had a mustache most
people which subconsciously is why I
want a must and most people who have
mustaches now have ironic mustaches so
we haven't gotten past irony when it
comes to the mutt the modern mustache
but a guy like Jason who we're about to
have the conversation that's an ironic
mustard he has an ironic mustache but
he's such a sincere guy that I don't
think he's just cool yeah it's just cool
but I'm saying so why can't I have that
why can't this be it can this be ironic
well that's actually real life what up
what of course it can I'm saying it
definitely is and that's kind of what I
wanted to say is that if I were to meet
meaning I don't have to fight fires I
saw I'm just concerned I don't know I'm
saying that this is and this is why I
want to have an extended like once we
complete your look okay and whatever
that's going to be I think we have to
have the conversation of what is the
interpretation of the mustache because
yes I think that we would both agree
that we don't want it to be interpreted
as an ironic mustache I don't totally
agree with what but maybe is it okay
there's a percentage is it okay if it's
just as ambiguous thing yeah because you
know okay
you know if I meet you in LA and I'm
like okay well his clothes fit you know
I'm saying it's like you don't have on
like a NASCAR shirt that's three sizes
too big not to click on the NASCAR
people I'm just saying that if you've
got a NASCAR shirt that's three sizes
too big and you got a moustache it's not
an ironic mustache I don't care how hard
you wish it is it's not right you also
have a volunteer fire department beeper
on your belt yeah right yeah exactly
if you work if you're a volunteer
fireman you have a mustache you have a
purposeful fireman's mustache and I
respect that but it's not our rod by the
way you know why the smoke it absorbs
the smoke it absorbed it filters the
smoke you still you still breathe the
smoke but you don't read the bad part
you know the real reason why firemen and
policemen have mustaches yeah I just
told you know the real reason yeah I
know that one but I'm not gonna tell you
the real reason is because it is the
only facial hair that is allowed in many
fire departments and police departments
the regulation beards are not allowed in
in the military or in most police
academy you know police forces in
probably fire department a man wants to
have I'm gonna have facial hair man well
we're gonna have it okay that's where
I'm gonna have it and so it became
associated it was actually the rete was
the result of a regulation that they had
no say in right that then became a
cultural association with people who do
a certain vocation hmm that's sweet
that's crazy and I'm I mean you are
allowed to be folded into that legis no
but there's nothing else about you that
says firemen no there's not nothing
right well I mean if the fire started
right here I could probably put it yeah
but no Matt would know better than me
know better than me well let let's let
us set a fire and find out yeah let's
let's not do that let's not presume that
I couldn't do it so you have I do have a
must you have an ironic mustache and
that may be okay I don't think there's
any way that it's not gonna be perceived
as ironic right but how would you feel
about yourself if you met yourself
because I can tell you how I feel about
you if I didn't know you we're growing
it out for role I'd be like oh this guy
thinks he's cool
oh is that it this guy thinks he's so
cool course and I would think the same
thing about me if I saw a guy with my
hair or what I mean right your hair too
you know even the beard yeah even the
beard in the context of where we live
yeah oh that guy's trying this guy's
trying too hard God thanks too much of
himself thinks he's cool cares too much
about his face so you spend too much
time on himself in the morning I'm fine
I'm flattered that you think no one
would have thought that about me before
the mustache I think they would have
thought that okay but I definitely think
but I think it's okay to think that I
kind of I mean I don't want you I don't
I'm not trying to make it seem like I
don't care what I look like I just
trying to conceal it a little bit but
when you do something that's like and
what I'm planning to do what I'm
planning to do potentially which I won't
reveal now it's kind of easily worse
it's way worse in an ironic mustache in
terms of what people would conclude
about me because of it way worse I would
say on a scale of one to ten when I'm
playing anyone doing is a nine on the
that guy is somebody I don't want to
have a conversation with so why are we
doing it because we can I think because
it is cool because I think it's cool I
don't kick you know it's like again we
get into why I have the tennis shoes I
have in the thing it's like I give it a
renoise you just made a clicking noise
when you spoke I thought that was cool
too lightly
I think it's cool to make it click how
did you do that but I think it's cool to
myself to make a clicking noise almost
sound like an artifact from life on the
microphone it was all in my mouth I
don't know how I did it
but it was very cool right yeah there
was no I think tip differently about
your mustache I think we're gonna be
posting footage of us Y all lots of
footage of not from buddy system from
the set of buddy system and I think that
will be the answer to your question yeah
the question that we put out there is
that isn't gonna have a mustache like
well you know you'll [ __ ] you'll find
out yeah and it's right gonna have
something else right right now I'm
thinking worse I'm thinking we're gonna
post those behind-the-scenes video
moments on the this is mythical channel
so be subscribed to that but if we don't
they'll be somewhere I'll just leave it
at that
not make any promises it's not a promise
it's just an assumption that may that
may change I like being a guy who has a
mustache for a little bit of time
because I know ultimately I will be a
guy without a mustache yeah I just like
be I like I like being different hmm
then myself and most of the population
has more taste hmm part of being cool is
that heathrow tastes out the window it's
like you know in spite of taste yeah
people who are cool don't don't even
know it
the coolest people don't even know it
yeah I think Jace is one of those guys I
think he is I think he is he said he was
such a like we try so hard we think
about all this being cool crabber try so
it's sad we calculate so we can unseal
ike we own calculator seem like you
don't hear some great thing he did and
we had a great conversation he had a and
he has a great moustache to go does
you'll see it in a second and you're
you'll hear it because you can that you
for just listening you can hear it hear
them a slight muffled sound of his voice
coming through that flavor saver it's
softened just the right amount by stache
but first we're going to take a short
break to let you know that we have Paul
made well hold on we have mythical
pomade do they all come dented why is
that one dent oh I think this may be
dented because I don't know I wasn't
that way when I got it it was that way
when it fell out of my chair rolled
around on the ground you drop it I did
it well I didn't dropping it with me I
had possession of it it was just in
between my legs and then it popped right
out you can't you're bad at possessing
things between your legs yeah now the
thing I want to talk about this you know
we've had this mythical pomade for a
while and it's it's it's what we do to
get our hair to look like it is you know
already know we care too much about the
cool look you're super cool you want to
be super cool yeah get this mythical
pomade but the thing that we wanted to
talk about today is the fact that this
is also very good for the ladies this is
not just a men's product just because
the two of us are men doesn't mean that
you have to be a man to use this product
there's a lot of a lot of the ladies
around mythical entertainment actually
use this to great
and because it's a it's light it's a
light it's a light limeade it's light on
its like a medium hold but it also has a
matte finish and so it's just very
versatile so we encourage even you
ladies to check out the mythical pomade
it's it's super high quality ingredients
make your hair magical all that get it
at rhettandlink.com/store do it and now
onto the biscuit I couldn't help but
notice you shoes when you walked in
because I feel like that's what people
probably look at first absolutely when
you walk into a room yeah you do but I
didn't look like directly Adam was like
staring at the Sun it was like can't I
look too long I don't want to be so what
what did you what did you wear in here
oh we got gold
just retro oh can you put can you put it
up here how flexible are you oh just
take the shoe off there we go a second
time wearing them so really it is ask
permission man oh man
Jason Hart sorry please can you touch
the shoes may I touch this [ __ ] I just
I've already touched it twice I'm blown
it please do please do is there an
etiquette oh yeah may I
yet you're only supposed to put your
finger in the back loop right like I you
know I don't think that I'm not with you
I'm like whatever you're not too
precious no but when touching other
people's shoes I'm conscious of like the
oils in my fingers and like when it's us
like this few doesn't really have any
like super delicate material is a subtle
way of saying you've already violated
the code language but if it was like a
suede I am kind of just really
particular about like okay
oils might transfer onto the suede so
I'm just gonna hold it from the midsole
mmm it's like when you go to a hat shop
like you know I I will buy the
occasional Fedora are you talking
brothers and I what is that you tell my
lids no no no I'm talking about like
Gorham Brothers like the the like the
Hat hat shop you know there's the one in
Pasadena there's there's you know about
Gorp like a cowboy hat and so know like
the fedoras are the
was aware so I go in there and for the
longest time I went in there and I was
grabbing the hat on top of the hat and
picking up Munna and then like the fifth
time I was in the store I saw a sign
that says please do not handle hats from
the crown crown you're supposed to take
the the the brim and hold everything
from the brim so what's the B so you
basically the equivalent of a brim of a
hat is the sole of the shoe I don't know
if that's etiquette no that's just sort
of my personal thing but I you know you
have the power to create etiquette
that's the beauty of it I don't know
about that but you did help create the
way people think about the cleanliness
of their sneakers yeah well I mean I
think like having clean sneakers is just
sort of goes hand in hand with being
sort of into sneakers I didn't create
that I think what I created was in some
ways ID it wasn't to make shoe cleaning
cool like you know I guess I guess it
just kind of became that as well I mean
I what I wanted to do was create a shoe
cleaner that was made specifically for
like the sneaker culture and sneaker
market yeah and you're talking about a
cleaning product cleaning product yeah
so just bring me up to speed so what it
what is it you do what what's the what's
the breadth of what your company does at
this point so you clean shoes you got a
product that cleans the shoes with
braids like what are they what are all
the facets of the business so it started
10 years ago and it started with a shoe
cleaner and that's it like I had a shoe
care a shoe cleaner kit it had like a 8
ounce bottle of cleaner and it came with
a brush and I had because that did not
exist
no well shoe cleaner existed it was just
more of like mass market stuff like
stuff that you would just find in the
mall and like you bought your shoes at
Foot Locker yeah and then at the at the
cashiers like hey why don't you let me
just give you those exactly yeah a
little squirt bottle of this stuff right
yeah so that stuff existed
I've tried it and I'm sure you know a
lot of people have but for me I just
personally didn't trust that stuff
because it was a you know aerosol can it
had this like spiky a cat cap that acted
as a supposed to supposed to be a brush
and it was the sharp like I don't we got
if you guys remember this but it was
like super sharp bristles so like I just
never I mean I've used it before back in
the day but I usually resorted to just
kind of making my own stuff at home you
want your shoe back yeah that that's a
clean shoe that is a sweet shoe I just
thought of you sitting there with one
sock on I was like we can't have a we
can't keep talking to Jason mark you got
one shoe on finish I kind of hope you
forget about I could keep one of his
shoes blue it man would remember when he
started walking I was about to grab it
and slowly start inching it to my side
of the table I would have noticed
he would have notice I would proudly
wear one shoe if it was that shoe yeah
okay so we should have discussed that
ahead of time okay yeah right so the
existing product was inadequate well I
mean yeah I just it was scary it looked
like a porcupine on top hundreds of
dollars on a shoe this is like a prized
possession right throw in this thing in
your bag like a polyurethane porcupine
it feels like an upsell yeah absolutely
and then I remember the bristles used to
break off and it was just wasn't the
best product but I think for me at least
the biggest thing was like sort of a
dish like not trusting what's in there
so I just I just go home and make my own
like dishwashing soap warm water
sometimes I'd mix like if it was like I
feel like to clean my laces if they were
white laces I'd put them in like a like
a little ziploc bag with like warm water
some dishwashing soap and some bleach
and I'd shake it up and they get really
bright white uh-huh but the thing is
like after one after you put your laces
back in the bleach would have weakened
the right the the lace and it would just
like pop like hairs
yeah we're just so there's certain
things that like there's certain tricks
you know that everybody has and so you
were so this was talking ten years ago
when you you wanted this for yourself
you were were you a self self-prescribed
sneakerhead uh yeah I was in the
sneakers forget about a vast collection
back then uh I had a good amount of
shoes you know I'm not like a I still
don't consider myself like a collector
first day like I just always been in the
shoes i everything that I buy I wear
yeah it's not like I like flip them or
my multiple pairs and I have this like I
now have a sneaker room now but like I
just used to have like boxes right no it
wasn't anything like thousands of pairs
right well the funny thing is is yeah I
think about like the way that we
approached shoes growing up you know
like we grew up together and especially
as a kid I think I didn't understand the
whole sneaker head thing until I became
an adult because as kids what we would
do is you'd get a new pair of shoes and
then you would just wear it
indiscriminately everywhere oh yeah just
got so dirty and you just knew how long
you had the shoes by how dirty the shoes
were but like when you play basketball
even in middle school I remember I
wasn't on the team I kept score for the
girls right and they need you baby shoes
you're close by you did not need any
more keeper shoes specific type of shoes
for that could have rollers yeah I could
have been barefoot yeah which is good
for your feet I'm told it wasn't clean
but I remember those first tennis shoes
tennis shoes basketball shoes that you
had do you didn't wear those out when
you were off the court did you I did I
did just like running through the field
so now first of all my son knew about
you had bought your kit because he's the
sneaker head of my family and he's also
he's a basketball player now he's gone
from diving to basketball and so he's
got his shoe collection and he has his
court shoes and and I was telling him
the other day I was like you realized
that our coach with first of all
everybody on the team got the same shoe
so now it's like everybody every player
gets their own shoes and that's that's
not something that's happened in the NBA
but now it happens in college and it
also happens in high school now we're
but we had the team shoe like every
button like the year the
came out mean god pumps our whole team
got the pumps that was big I would wear
those pumps not only would I wear them
to school I would wear them when I
played street ball in my front yard on
my street on the like the really rough
gravel and I and then I would wonder why
when I was in the game I had no traction
at all you'd be sliding around like air
hockey and it's like it I don't know why
no one told us how we should think about
things like why didn't somebody why
didn't i coach you say you guys
shouldn't wear these shoes anywhere but
this court because you need the traction
that they were designed to have it's
like lock it just blew his mind that
that was something that we did but we
just we didn't understand shoes you know
honestly like I'd wear my shoes on the
black court when I play in the gym it
was one of those things where is this
like I wasn't broke but I didn't have
all the money in the world to buy like
all the shoes that I wanted to buy so I
just right where I mean try to keep them
clean as possible which actually made it
more important to keep your right yeah
you know it's they would get dirtier and
you wanted to look you weren't just
gonna go out and buy another another
pair you gonna get them clean right so
were you always like meticulously
cleaning and trying to figure that out
yeah I mean I think just my personality
is I'm a little bit of a clean freak you
know just even outside of shoes yeah you
do yeah a bit I'm a bit OCD you're not a
shoe clean freak I'm not as know but but
in many things because I think that most
people think of it like okay if I get if
I got a shirt and it's got like a
mustard stain on it I'm like I can't
wear that but then for some reason they
believe that that rule stops at the
ankle right and they're like well I got
a weird grass stain on my shoe but but
that but a lot more pricey but explain I
want to I just help people understand
the mentality behind seeing the
cleanliness of shoes as being as
important as the cleanliness of your
shirt absolutely I mean I think the the
the reason why I like to go back like
when I created the logo the original
logo has a speech bubble in it I don't
know if you've seen it but it has a
speech bubble and the whole thought
behind that was like your sneakers are
an expression or statement like you
basically you don't have to say anything
and it's sort of like you look at the
person's shoes and you're like okay like
what's up you know like yeah I know I
know you know it's like game recognize
game type of thing so keeping your
sneakers clean like you couldn't just
walk out the house with busted sneakers
because they it just it it's complete
your whole outfit right what you're
wearing so it was that something that
you don't want to look like a hobo from
the angry town right so like your group
of friends where you was it something
that like everybody understood this
don't go out of the house with busted
shoes or was this something that you
kind of brought - no it was sort of like
amongst my peers yeah like that were in
the shoes you kept them clean as
possible as much as possible and I think
you know well but the big thing with me
was like growing up was playing
basketball like I thought I was gonna be
the first Asian like pro player you know
which like seeing were you far from it I
thought it was so good you know I
thought I was so good and I really was
not that good you know I was like in the
eighth grade I remember just like
playing and just dribbling circles
around like my teammates and just didn't
know luck passes and everything and I
get to high school and I remember trying
out for the the freshman basketball team
and I was just like it was just like a
huge awakening that I really was not
that good I I tried out I went to summer
uh whatever summer camp and then I
didn't make the team and then I tried
out again for the sophomore team I
didn't make the team and it was like
okay you really you really not good but
you can look good yeah yeah I was just
fine it was it was it was you know that
was a big part of growing up was playing
ball yeah well that I mean that's what
that's what got and both actually both
of our kids are more into shoes than we
are that's what got them and issues is
that we started taking them to like Mike
my kids we're not in into basketball at
all which was my sport growing up
because like I said Locke was in the
diving there's no shoes for diving
there's just a little speedo it's kind
of embarrassing to wear hmm
and keep it clean but taking him to the
Clippers games I know you're a Lakers
fan
Clippers man we did we want to talk
about we won't even talk yes that's
already brought it up and because of
that our boys got into baseball they got
a basketball which leads you shoes real
was actually getting an Xbox and then
they got 2k NBA 2k yeah which they
started playing the video game and then
you again then we started going to
basket NBA games we're but you start to
see a shower all that's how all the
businesses are so related right it's
like oh gonna get you into this this
game and then you're gonna want to
understand how to win the game because
the game is so realistic actually
watching basketball happen is gonna help
you play the game better oh I'm actually
interested in this what are these guys
into oh they're really into their shoes
they all have and now I'm in issue so
now lock has I had to install these like
two shelves next to his bed where he's
got you know all his shoes and then like
then we had and we had an agreement I
was like when you beat me in horse I'll
buy you a pair of shoes and that finally
happened like two months ago so then I
did buy a pair of shoes so it's like
would you know what did he actually he
went with us to he couldn't bear to
riffle a okay and he couldn't pick out a
pair but they got stage Friday we know
what he did he got much to my
disappointment he got the Duke themed
kairi's and I'm an NC State grad and my
wife was a UNC grad and he got the Duke
theme Tyrese are they called the flat
earthers no be good yeah you look you
you raised up the bottom and it's got
like a map all know he's got the earth
on the door as flat as it actually is
that's good we I I incidentally I
tweeted Kyrie a lot whenever I see like
a NASA video of that shows the roundness
of the earth I just at him just to
remind him that it is round and what
does he say bad he doesn't say anything
bad oh he doesn't know Kyrie has never
but he's busy he doesn't mean awesome
shoes though handles too that's what we
play ball every Wednesday and that's
what I that's what I wrote in the car
yeah there's three pairs at our house my
eight-year-old has a pair that he plays
it and his basketball league then my and
then Locke has two pair but how did it
go from you you wanted to formulate your
own cleaner just for yourself or was it
immediately a business
idea well I've always been sort of like
business minded I've always wanted to be
my own boss I've written like business
plans that never really panned out and I
was cleaning my sneakers one night and I
was using my homemade concoction or
whatever and it was like I told you it's
like a mix of OxiClean dishwashing soap
and warm water and like a toothbrush and
I was cleaning my shoes and I was like
like that was sort of like the first aha
moment like there's got to be like I'm
using household cleaners to like clean
my shoes there's got to be a better way
so I didn't know if like I wasn't aware
of something existing right specialized
for the sneak remark so I just or if you
were onto something right yeah so I did
I you know jumped around the internet
didn't really see anything that was like
special I I go to like sneaker lineups
and tell my local sneaker shop at that
time I was living in Harbor City so
proper in Long Beach was like my spot
and I'd go down there and just ask
people like what do you hey what do you
use to clean your sneakers and everybody
had a recommend date it wasn't like oh
go use XYZ product it was a take a white
tip eraser do that use a tide pen oh you
know if you do this and you kind of you
mix that with this and that's when I was
sort of like okay there's something here
now and right so that was sort of the
real aha moment so what was the next
step so then come up what come up with a
name or come up with a formula the
formula oh yeah so I'm not I'm not a
chemist
you know I I so the first once I knew I
had like the opportunity an idea there
what I wanted to create I started
googling chemists like really yeah
chemists in my neighborhood like you
like to show cars my Yelp to chemists
first it was 10 years ago no it was like
chemist Los Angeles and then in you know
the language was like contract
manufacturing is like okay contract
chemist and so like I would just you
know that's where I had met like my main
chemist but I went through two two
chemists before landing on him and being
like okay he gets it you know
hmm
well how hard is it to get make
something really good to clean to use
that's the thing that's the thing is
like you would you know so the first guy
that I had called so yeah come down
whatever and I just trying to explain to
him exactly what I wanted to do my
vision like you know the first priority
for me was making it safe so people
don't even have to think twice like oh I
could clean my sneakers I'm just gonna
go grab that product and use it I might
eat my sneaker later yeah yeah so yeah I
was just that was the first thing and
the guy was like X shook leaner I could
make you shoe cleaner all day like we
could we could you you could do your
logo here it was just he wasn't really
trying to hear me out you know I got you
I'm and and the same with the second guy
and then the third guy who I ended up
going with I remember I called him I was
working my full-time job I was working
in advertising and I called him on my
lunch break and we talked to like an
hour and a half and I was just just
talking about the vision and what I what
I wanted to do and how important it was
that it didn't you know damage swayed or
that it didn't turn the shoe yellow and
I was trying to explain to him there's
so many different grades of suede and
there's patent leather and he's like
what's patent leather so like a red flag
yeah so I was just you know after
speaking to him for like an hour and a
half I set up a meeting and I remember I
brought it I brought in like five or six
different pairs of shoes and we sat in
his office and it was just like
educating him on like materials mmm
which was which was a trip the next step
was I went out and bought like every
shoe care product that I can find that
was on the market that I did some that I
didn't even use it was just like like
here you go here's what's on the market
and here's like my vision and direction
and this is what I want to create and it
was just off to the races from there and
then how long did it take to develop the
secret formula I took about I want to
say less than six months it wasn't it
was a lot of testing like he'd he'd he'd
give me like three or four different
samples to take home and then I go test
them and then I'd write my notes and
feedback like oh you know I wanted it to
foam
more right it doesn't clean that well on
you know rubber or vulcanized soles or
different types of things I write it
back and I give them the feedback and
then like another two three weeks later
you'd be like oh I got some more samples
from you come come pick them up and then
once you had what you decided was you
know the final formula like what was the
transition from quitting your day job to
kind of chasing this dream once I had
the formula I doubt that's when the fun
stuff like it was the formula and then
it was like picking the color and
picking the smell and then like and then
what's it what was it called or was gone
well jason mark it's my first and middle
name but it so that was all like the
like I I'm pretty creative minded so
like that was where I like I was like
okay now I could mm-hmm I could call it
this and I had something advertising mom
yeah just like it was just I felt you
know that was like my zone you know so
like there's very few things that are
satisfying is like if you've got an
advertising mind taking that and
applying it to something that you're
trying to yeah like as opposed to like
taking all the energy and trying to sell
somebody else's product that you may not
believe in right right and different
yeah I think I don't that yeah exactly
just that it was mine you know like a I
really took the time to like really
think it through and I had some cheesy
names and like what you remember uh I
think the ones in know more more that's
good no more marks yeah I think the the
one that was like the front winner which
I think back now is really cheesy but I
was gonna call it sneak peak shoe
cleaner likes like sneaker like sneak
and like peak like a mountain like keep
them in peak condition a sneak peak mean
but I mean yeah I remember
you could have like a creepy dude
looking over a fence no that's using the
name though it almost makes it it makes
it seem like a premium product in some
way right it doesn't seem like a gimmick
product no I know it doesn't it doesn't
and the I remember the exact like
morning where it kind of like dawned on
me like oh use your name was um I was
brushing my teeth and I go to open the
medicine with it with
not them now with the problem I've
actually tasted the product
yeah if any I'd love to taste it right
now not very good tasting it I would not
recommend it probably but I taste great
compared to some of us we've been fed
around here that's true I opened a
medicine cabinet and I had a Paul Smith
um like bottle of lotion or face cream
or something and I was like oh
Paul Smith that's the designers name you
know like that's pretty like timeless I
guess like it's not trendy yeah so I was
like oh I'm gonna call it we call it my
middle name is mark but it's spelled
with one K and the reason I added the
extra K was I wanted it to be kind of
easy to search like I don't know how
many Jason mark with 1 K there but with
2 K is probably not that many yeah it's
important man yeah it's important that
key word thing I see I gotta keep
googling I got to get that SEO going so
you had that and you're you know you're
working on it all of your your marketing
mojo but then you've got it like I mean
you've got like a like a nest egg that
you're put you're investing in
manufacturing or something I I like to
raise money I this was 2000 I launched a
company in 2007 and the development and
all that was like 2006 and I remember I
put together like this PowerPoint deck
and I invited my family over hopefully I
was living with my parents
but inviting invited them into living
room my I had like like you know my
favorite auntie and like my sisters and
their husbands and we had dinner I cook
remember I cooked dinner for them oh
yeah they knew something was up
you know it was just weird why are you
getting us drunk and then I remember it
like busting out my laptop and like
walking them through my presentation and
I raised like I don't know like fifteen
thousand dollars like my my sister would
give me like five my parents gave me
like that like whatever I remember it
mounted to like under 20 and that's what
I had to work with so like like whoops
I like like production Ron like the
first production run well if you know
you know if if you believe in something
that you're doing and you can convince
the people that love you and have the
means to support it to support it that's
yeah and I believe that we do it for
sure I just figured what are they gonna
do Dee family yeah yeah I think that's
cut disowned no more powerpoints yeah
they're gonna ban you from powerpoints
in the living room yeah so happen not
didn't happen they supported me and they
still they still do very much support
yeah so you made your first batch right
or you had it made
I had it made and then I mean what was
this I mean what's the strategy how does
this things like it from yeah so I think
the first production run the minimum was
like 2500 units or something like that
if I remember correctly and back when
when I launched it was packaged in this
like mini sneaker box and I remember I
had a like a like a filling pizza party
like at my sister's house I got pictures
somewhere but it was just like you know
three three or four six foot tables and
it was literally like me filling bottles
by hand we had those you know those
Gatorade like you know those orange
Gatorade like you thought soccer games
yeah like a pool or yeah we got Home
Depot and I remember I got two of those
and I got like a piece of rubber hose
that would like go on to the spigot and
it would just prevent like foam so you
should put the hose in the bottle and
you'd like fill each wine mm-hmm and so
we had like a filling party we had like
an assembly line people making like many
sneaker boxes I ordered pizza and and it
was it was it was fun it was fun you
know I took it took back in the day used
to take me like a twenty five hundred
unit run would last me like a whole year
which and you would sell it out of your
house and also out of those sneaker
shops no I I so basically what I did
before I even quit my job I think going
back to that question was I had the
product but I didn't launch it
officially and I I felt like I might
need to have some sales skills
so like my younger brother at the time
he was selling kitchen cutlery you know
like one of those when you go like
campuses and people hands you like those
flyers and it's like yo like need a job
doing a door knife so yeah literally
cook oh yeah yeah shut out we've had a
couple of Cutco situations I still use
cut coke
Joey came to my house man Joey came to
my house selling me Cutco III cut me
that was his tactic I've had him for 16
years I had him sharpened last year yeah
well Joey would break out the knife and
like he would threaten you with it
that's how he'd that so I'm now whole
freakin set he had that thing that the
clincher moment in the presentation
where he would cut a penny with that
other scissors yeah yeah yeah gotta cut
those Thanks oh man so so yeah that I
basically quit my advertising job and
then I but you got your you you got your
brother was a knife sales but he wanted
to be a he was a salesman and he had his
own like office in Torrance like he had
his own he was running his own say lots
of knives
yeah people selling selling for him yeah
yeah yeah and I saw his I saw his sales
manual one day and I was just like
flipping through it it was like the it
was like the ABCs of selling like how to
handle yeah objections and all that and
I was like this is this is really good
stuff you know like I might need I it
helps when you have a sharp knife that's
step one yeah with the handling
objections yeah I just I was like you
know like I want to learn how to sell so
I he hired me I was funny had to go
through this whole interview process and
like I was you know he hired me for a
summer and I saw you didn't hire your
brother no yeah you asked him to hire
you that could learn and he had me it
wasn't just like you like you got the
job it was like I remember sitting in
the it was like this bungalow it was it
was like there was like three people
ahead of me and they were all like four
in there for energy and it's like my
brother do you like hire me like what do
you well I had to go opinion yet so you
sold knives to learn how to sew yeah
yeah but I just never it well I get
maybe I did use some of the knowledge
that I picked up but
yeah so I sold knives for a summer I
almost sold like $30,000 worth of knives
and I was like at that point I was like
okay I'm done like I'm good like yeah
yeah I'm pretty good like I don't need
to like you know so I quit it was only
like I was only there for like three
three months three four months mm-hm and
then I okay so I had the product and
then before I quit before I quit my job
at the advertising agency I like hit up
all my homies that were like in the
creative departments like the designers
and I was just like yo I'm gonna quit I
mean like two weeks would you help me
like design logos and something like
yeah so like I just kind of like built a
team there before I left and then and
then um and then yeah so they I had the
logo I had the name at the packaging and
and actually the guy that is that is my
main creative director today is is the
guy who designed my logo ten years ago
Oh Adam you came yeah so he's been on
the whole he's seen the whole thing from
he designed the logo and he's designed
like every piece of packaging that we
have we've done in the last ten years
and at this point it's moved well beyond
the selling the individual packs right
well I did I didn't even I died so I
didn't even launched yet but what I did
was I created like a I knew how to
create a press kit like from like
advertising and whatnot and well my best
friend was like a graphic designer and I
remember um so basically like a which is
a swag box that you send to people who
can like talk about how great it is yeah
yeah yeah right articles are stuff for
ya and you had to like have you know
pretty good quality pictures all that
stuff so I remember we shot the pictures
in his garage and like IKEA lights and I
gotta find the originals but there were
so photo shots because like the lighting
was bad and shadows and but it worked so
I put I put all this stuff into like a
press packet and I just remember this
was 2007 I remember hitting up like all
the blogs it was like Hite bees do a
slam hype mr. Kim says it was like the
jeff staples of the world and those guys
that had blogs and I just would hit them
up like those are sneaker heads those
are like yeah sneaker like Street Street
wear
vlogs and I would just like email the
info line and like hey my name is Jason
I'm starting this company I have this
product like can I send you out a kit
and so a lot of like yeah in the back
and back when it was like easy it was
like yeah
and before they even got it was like oh
we'll post it I sent them the email the
thing and then there will post it on
this date at this time and I'm like holy
like this is super cool and they did
like they really just so when it
launched I was prepared to go door to
door like if I had it if I had to like
go door to door and when it launched it
got on all the blogs and I got all I got
tons of emails like from around the
world like instantly it was like global
and I didn't even have a website
I had a splash page with like you had a
logo and you click it and it would open
like a like an info like a email info at
Jason mark comedy just like tight so
like I remember it launched and like you
couldn't take people's money mm-hmm and
and emails and it was like just emails
and I would I would be processing these
orders like via email like how many kids
did you want and that's gonna be $25 and
then I was like I was the customer
service guy was the shipping guy was
everything in there pen pal
but initially yeah pepper in there pen
pal yeah yeah so it was crazy it was
like you know I was into the South Bay
southern what Southern California and I
thought you know I'm gonna launch it
here
and I'll probably have to drive up to
San Francisco just thinking about like
accessible cities maybe San Diego and
just if I had to go hustle and I never
thank God I never really had to go like
door-to-door it was just stores from
around the world saying I want to carry
your product right and this there was no
product out there yet yeah it was just
based off of I guess the branding
packaging and you know the press kit I
guess and all the press that I got at
what point didn't at some point you
expanded to where there was an actual
cleaning service right I mean yes I need
that come along that was about three
years ago so company had it had it there
so six years after your launch six or
seven years seven years
I was I wanted to open a store like a
physical store because we we had a
pretty good loyal following on social
media and people would like follow us
and like do all that but I just felt
like it was this I remember I remember
how the store came up because I was
doing a trade show in Vegas it was like
agenda or might have been magic or one
of the ones and I remember we had a
great show and I remember sitting there
and I was sitting around marketing guys
now like for the trade show are you like
you got one of those microphones you're
like all right step right up camber your
shoes I can make any shoes clean no
that's not very cool that's not cool
I don't think though we're not gonna get
the right clientele do it yeah we we
Olay they gave us like a free booth old
ladies got money old money's worth just
my ladies got old dirty shoes different
type of trades yeah definitely yeah we
just we had a booth and it was just such
a great reception and and I was just
like what do we do now and for some
reason it was like let's open a store
like that's the next I think that's the
next thing to do is open a store and had
you expanded the product offerings
beyond the initial kit or really I mean
I I remember for like the first five or
six seven years we literally had like
five SKUs and I and I just we had that
we had like we had the Broadway of the
towel we had two brushes we had the
cleaner and I think we've we did like a
handful of collabs at that point with
like really like cool sneaker shops like
undefeated that was the first one that
we did and then we did noir that was in
New York Bay sneaker boutique and then
we did staple design and it was just
like collabs were and we still do
several collabs now so that give me an
example like what kind of product is it
it was just like I remember it like the
first undefeated one they basically just
took the kit it was a it was an eight
ounce bottle and a brush in a little
mini sneaker box and they just like they
just flipped everything right about it
so like the packaging and the pattern
and the color of the bottle and the sand
and the labels and we just did like
eliminated run of like a thousand pieces
and and then from that that can't just
like we're off off and running in it
it in and of itself became a collector's
ID yeah when you look at it
limited-edition and stuff and yeah this
was 2007 but then when you want to make
a store so that's the next step
it was not just to sell the product but
also to all TPS started out an epicenter
for a service no like it just the
concept for the store was simply to
create a space where people can come and
experience the Jason Mark brand like
past the computer you know it's just
like what are these guys into what are
they listening to you like sight smells
like let's talk sneakers and just the
play it was really really a place to buy
product and then like as I was designing
the space out we had this we call it the
JM throne it's like this old-school shoe
shine chair and we had one of them and
we got it made in Atlanta and like it
was just it was it was like trap it was
like being sent to different stores we
did a pop-up shop at read space where we
had the chair and people will come and
get free could we call him quick cleans
and then like it was just gaining I
guess popularity we would okay they saw
that reads based on name on it at
wherever what you know so with this
chair would just travel and the
experience that people would get was
just like I don't know if you've ever
got your shoes clean before but it is
sort of like a oh well it's it
definitely is an experience it just
feels like I don't know comforting yeah
I don't think I've never had a shoe shoe
shine or shoe clean but I was told that
it's like a it feel it's kind of like a
massages it is very dirty right
especially when you don't have a shoe on
no more like well that's not that is a
massage that's just a foot massage
that's just a foot massage with shoe
polish yeah that's a weird fad and I
probably should have brought it up right
okay but this is something that you
offered yeah so we were just doing we're
just doing these chair like the chair
tour I guess and then as we're designing
the store I'm like okay well I want the
chair it's become sort of you know it
goes hand in hand with the Jason mark
brand I want the chair in the in the
front of the store and then I was like
oh well why don't we just do a service
and I really underestimated it at that
point I didn't think I had this big like
oh this is like the next thing yeah it
was a cool idea it was just the next
step in an evolution yeah what you were
doing with it right totally makes sense
though because in retrospect you've got
people who like the idea of cleaning
their shoes and then you like people you
didn't there's a much wider circle which
is people who just like to have clean
shoes but like you know saying but like
am I gonna actually especially like you
would probably like be like okay I'm
gonna take this afternoon and I'm gonna
clean these shoes and that's gonna be
fun and I would be like ah I can't get
somebody to do this so that I mean that
it just totally makes sense to me that
if you care about that and especially if
you know that you're not doing a good
job and there's somebody who's a
professional that's a right but you had
the chair in the store and it was still
just like part of the experience of
being there it was ya know it was just
sort of meant to be like the Instagram
moment but yeah oh I met the Jason mark
store let me go sit in the J M throne
and like get my snap on uh my you know
my ig on and and that's what it was the
chair was there for and then we I
started thinking I was like oh won't we
just do like some type of chop off
cleaning service and and a totally again
just really underestimated the whole
thing and it's kind of grown into this
thing where it's just like I never would
have thought I just didn't even expect
that like it would be what it is at this
point you've got like celebrity clients
who like you're their guy yeah yeah we
we've had a you know we've had a fair
amount of celebrities come in a lot of
basketball players we've had DeAndre
Jordan come in with Jordan Clarkson
we've had swaggy P come in PJ Tucker
who's a big sneaker head and we've had
like hip-hop artists you know we've had
we've kept Kelly Rowland come in like
like two days in a row
really shoes though different shoes not
the same I'm back had a rough night I'm
back but the typical experience if I
were to go in there I would drop them
off and then come back and pick them up
like a dry cleaner yeah exactly
as simple as that it's just so you
take another pair of shoes to wear out
link just planning ahead for you what I
would probably maybe carry them in a bag
into you like changed my shoes in there
yeah most people do that okay strategic
thing yeah so it's just this it's just
it's to put it simply like that's how I
explain it to people like I strike it's
dry cleaning for sneakers or there are
the people in the back who are cleaning
are they doing something different than
I could do at home with your products
they did a special thing or is it the
same thing and they they used it's the
same product but what it is is like
they've come up with different
techniques and methods on how that
unique it's like it's serious it's like
a real it's a real thing like we believe
it we encourage people to like buy the
product obviously like go buy the
product do it at home but a lot of times
people have that really special pair
that meet that has right whether whether
it has a big you know monetary value to
it or a sentimental value and they're
they just don't want to they're just
like I don't want to mess it up I'd
rather have you guys do it and so we get
that a lot
so I imagine that most people are
bringing in their prized possession
shoes there is not like normal people
just like I got these like nasty kids no
we can't we get it we get it all that's
the thing and I think the kids I think
the part of the reason why don't crow no
we get it all we get like just like your
basic whatever sneaker and then we get
we even get like the designer like
Balenciaga as we get Saint Laurent we
get all the crazy like Plus really rare
like really rare sneakers as well and
then we just get we get everything
what's the what's the most I learned and
just going into riff because you're
Dwight right now right across the street
friend Rasta Street going down there
with Locke and seeing like this special
case would I think they had a seventeen
thousand dollar pair in there what at
one point it was the give us those green
oh yeah that joy undefeated forest yeah
yeah yeah yeah and that was oh no no it
wasn't the undefeated 4s it was the M&M
fours yeah and it was like like I think
it was like a size 14 it was apparent
don't quote me on this well apparently
the only one in the world I don't know
it was like really rare but yeah we get
stuff like that yeah and so at that
point it seems like it's like paint
painting restoration you know like
you've got the lady who took that old
picture of Jesus and made him look like
an owl remember that from a couple years
ago you remember that she like cuz
that's like we actually I knew a guy who
I know you just did an ala find Jesus
worked at a museum and specializes in
paint painting like restoration and
preservation and of course you know they
come in there and there's a million
dollar painting it's like you have to
use the right chemicals and everything
it's it's a it's a slightly less
expensive version of that but you are
dealing with people's like babies we are
and that's that's the sort of
nerve-wracking thing like especially
during the first year because it was I
again underestimated the whole thing but
we just you know we didn't realize how I
didn't realize how fulfilling it would
be it was just I thought it was just
like you know as a service that people
may or may not use it goes hand in hand
with the brand we offer a cleaning
product mm-hmm and and we'll clean shoes
and you know we'll use our product and
it's just a it's a it's an icebreaker to
let go have you used you know just the a
thing and but it became fulfilling with
someone hand you their baby right and it
seemed at seeing the reaction was the
craziest craziest thing but then there's
also like you got people in tears like
you gave me mine Jordans beautiful we
had we had one customer who was who
actually was brought to tears like a
nice it was it was it was a it was a
pair of 85 Air Jordan ones oh gee and I
guess they were in a there were her
dad's and it was like you know she found
him in a Shack or like backyard jack and
they were like beat up super beat up and
it was father father's day was was
coming up and she asked us to you know
bring him back and I remember this was
like maybe six months of being open or
something so I had told it wasn't even
thought even about like turn
shoes like I told my staff like just
make sure the customer is happy that's
it I don't care like we're supposed to
be spending a certain amount of time on
a certain service you know that's a
business like you're making a sort of
margin and all that I just threw that
all at the window back especially for
the first year like I just want you to
focus on doing a great job I don't care
if you take two hours to clean the pair
of shoes like I don't care mm-hmm
and they did and they they brought these
this these Jordans back and she had come
to pick them up and she was literally
like like brought to tears and that I
was I had just happened to be there like
oh my like behind the maybe up this
cubby system were the shoes and I just
happen to be kind of like watching like
I was like this is all worth it you
imagine how much the dad bald I bet he
was in tears in like my guys they're
just like how you should so you should
go buy this acrylic case and like giving
her tips on like how to present it to
him uh-huh are there people who bring in
maybe it's a kid or maybe it's a high
dollar she's stuck on kids man I just
you have a pair of kid I really still I
love kids I stepped in something bad and
I stepped all the way in it like nothing
some Dookie yeah we just like Dookie
stuff bad disease get there's at least
$12 the worst pair of shoes we've ever
gotten we're a pair of babes and they
were covered in blood soaked in blood
like real blood yeah
real blood and what my boss so he he had
a fourth of July accident and he like
almost blew off his hand oh and he was a
friend he was a friend like a firework
yeah yeah and I saw it I met the guy so
he's he was a friend of my main guy that
was kind of like running we call him
that the sneaker care technicians is
something that we came up with their
assets for short SCT and he was like my
lead s18 he was like I got this homey
and he's got these pair of babes in
their bloody and like I want to I want
to bring them in and I want to like I
want to do before and after and I'm like
what like how what like is it evidence
before very bloody no he's like is in
evidence he was a good question yes like
you know
Franny had accident I'll introduce all
intro you and stuff so I remember he
came to the shop and you know I met the
dude and was it was like it was his
thumb when his hand was still kind of
swollen like a had healed okay but it
was like you could tell something like
right that blown up in there yeah yeah
so light it throw it
mm-hmm or set it down then light it then
run away or don't purchase at all or
light or throw I don't firework I'm talk
about fireworks now right but Who am I
Who am I to say what I've done a lot of
stupid stuff in my life so so did you
did you go for it yeah yeah yeah they I
was like okay well as long as they're
not like you know again like evidence or
some crazy that would be mixed up in it
okay yeah I met the dude I was like
alright and I was like just make sure
you wear like protective you know gloves
and wear clothes make sure you're like
all covered up and and they did and it
was just like they brought the pair of I
looked brand new honestly and luckily it
was like it was it wasn't like I don't
think the shoe had a nice weight on it
or anything like anything about it was a
but it but it was but the sock liner and
everything hat it wasn't just like on
the outside the shoe it was like does he
do clean himself up with his shoes it
was time I'm gonna stick my hand in my
shoe like it's a glove and now I'm gonna
do it the other one and what about
Spanky shoes like how often is it like
this is all her shoes but the real
problem is stink yeah we we get a lot of
those and what and you have like a
powder are you yeah we we do a
combination of things like if it I have
if it's really basking for a friend okay
if it's really bad um like we've even
stuck them in the freezer overnight to
kind of kill all the bacteria and we we
currently use this like this
antibacterial like it's pretty it's just
rank called Rita and they're out of
Japan and it's just kind of really like
elevated fragrance company that makes a
like a shoe spray so that's what we use
but it so if you're if you got the
stanky kids you can you can put them in
the freezer you can and it will
yeah makes total sense that's probably I
mean that's what we
used to do like in our first year now
it's just like really giving it a
thorough like really taking out the the
insole and really giving the whole
inside and you know giving a good spray
if I may oh I'm wondering this is my
shoe I just took it off my right foot I
would like for you to just give it a
left one - I mean just assess well what
I mean
it's what does this say about me that
I'm wearing these shoes and based on you
know profile me and then profile the
shoe tell me everything you know about
me and the shoe based on this I mean as
far as a it's a pretty it's a it's a
dope shoe I mean it's a what are these
the these at rainbow I don't even know
exactly what I don't know though he
knows though Bono's I know they're a
trainer they're in pretty relatively
good shape pretty relatively pretty
really pretty pretty relatively good
shape
that means not greately I don't know too
much about him all I know is I watched
that documentary sneakerheads
yeah and in the middle of it I said I
turn to my family because we were all
watching I was like these people are
assessing about their sneakers this is
kind of inspiring I never got to in the
sneakers but I remember I had one pair
that I was like the bojack's and Bono's
shoes I really wanted and my dad got him
for me for my birthday
you wore those things everywhere and I
remember when I got him I remember
opening the box I remember taking him
out it was like the only pair of shoes
that I obsessed about wanting and I was
like and I am gonna do something I never
do I'm gonna make an impulse buy I'm
gonna go on the internet I'm gonna find
him I'm gonna order some right now
because right I don't even know a
problem was it was a reissue absolutely
I did not yeah I did not to me it wasn't
I was tempted to be like alright do I
want I bet you can get the original I
bet the cost a lot of money I bet
they've reissued them if they have I'm
not gonna this is for me I'm not gonna
like obsess about what this would be to
anybody else or if they're actually
valuable and I was like I'm just gonna
make
impulse buying I'm gonna enjoy it and so
that's how I should I assume that these
aren't actually valuable to anybody
except me that's a reason I think I
think like walking down the street and
another another sneak we do which sort
of recognize like though you know those
are the bones just sort of like a head
nod like it's a classic shoot I think
it's a you know for me like classic
silhouettes like I don't go that's why
you mentioned like oh I don't know how
much these are worth or there's much
hype but I always wear what I like you
know I never have I never I mean if it's
if it were - it is velcro strap that's
useless like that offer some support on
the foot I read about him a little bit
right after I ordered him and one of the
reviews said they're not I wouldn't
recommend wearing them for for a cross
train from now but this is this is the
first cross cross training shoe yeah how
to start somewhere bow are they dirty
enough to be cleaned already oh yeah I
mean yeah I mean this would be like if
you brought these into the shop there
should be like a $10 clean yeah yeah
where you should just and they would
look they would look you know you would
you would definitely be happy it's not
like oh I could've you know we just
because it's a classic clean our basic
clean it's not like we just take you
know a few minutes on it this would be
cool to do like and I sit on the throne
you could definitely sit on the throne
it means is there a is there still like
clean them while they're on your foot
service door we can make we don't have
that currently but we could make that
happen like what what what would do with
the shoot with it with the throne is
like when we like we just had our
three-year anniversary mhm uh last week
and we'll do just free free quick liens
like you jump up there and we'll clean
your shoes for you so what's next for
for you I mean you've got E you've got
this knack for knowing where there's a
need and then you're I mean it's think
creating things that are just hits I
mean what's the next one are you doing I
for our ten-year anniversary
you know we're we've got a whole new
bunch like a whole new line of product
coming out so we've been working really
hard on that
I'm really excited about that so in the
next you know month or two you start to
see some of those drops happening um
definitely looking to expand this that
the service and the retail we only have
the one right now in Little Tokyo but we
I'm looking at New York so you got an
event coming up in New York that I think
we won't be this won't be live before
that right what wouldn't don't you have
there's like some pop-up thing that
you're doing in New York we uh or is
this something you did do in New York
maybe yeah yeah we've had a number yeah
I think I think yeah we've had last year
we did two pop-ups in America and so
we've we've we always have something
going on in New York whether it's like
an active you know one day or two day
thing at a retailer or something like
that but yeah we had a couple pop-ups
last year and I'm looking for a space to
have a permanent flagship okay well I'll
tell you man we we really appreciate you
coming in I mean it's been really
inspiring to hear all that you've
developed and all you've done and you
know even if you're not in the sneakers
like I mean I'm I'm very much into Bo
Jackson sneakers you're into one
particular pair of sneakers you know I I
think that there's a there's lots to be
inspired by so congratulations on all
the success thank you and thanks for
coming in and I really appreciate you
guys having me we'll come down and sit
on the throne
just like kings please do that would be
dope if you brought those pair of bows
in and we did before and after school
I'll be cool let's do it yeah
[Music]
there you have it our ear biscuit with
mr. Jason Mart were you inspired by his
story what's inspiring right yeah I've
got lots of ideas right now um do you
yeah yeah yeah that the one thing I said
about the shoeshine that would know with
no shoe that's a foot massage I got a
lot of ideas about that the shoeless
shoeshine draw people in
who wants a shiny foot man no it's about
the massage it's for a men who are
self-conscious about getting foot
massages but are going in for the
shoeshine and you get him in there you
shine the shoe and then you say hey look
at that cool bird shoe sharks coming off
and you get him to look at something and
then you I said shoe shark I meant to
say shoe starts yeah shoe shark coming
up you get him to shart maybe that's
what you do and then you pull the shoe
off and you start missing now I'm not
gonna do it I don't believe I'm not into
that I got strong hands but I'm not
really into touching people's feet I
like birds do like birds and anyway I'm
just think he's susceptible to birds
being pointed out to me it was
inspirational inspirational conversation
to a guy just I got an idea and now I'm
going to so many people so many people
just talk they just went like babies
just talking just talking and never
saying anything I'm gonna do this you
were talking
Jason mark making our point he's your
aunt over make her dinner we're talking
about what you're going to do and start
cleaning do it okay quit talking make a
pathway we're already inspired I'm just
saying you don't need to shame them
people just talk they just do a lot of
talking not you nothing some honey out
there not somebody somebody you weed
you're a talker we believe in you become
a doer you're great at PowerPoint at
least do the PowerPoint for the person
who's gonna do so let us know what you
think at hashtag ear biscuits oh you
went but at hashtag your business I
don't even think that's the thing but I
know what you mean I understand oh just
do it okay yeah you know how to do it I
apologize for him will speak etching
next week
[Music]